in the spirit. Okay, guys, let's begin.
Let's see how it's going to go.
Jewish guy named Yossi. I've blocked him
on my YouTube channel, but Diego asked
me to talk to him, so let's see how it's
going to work.
Yeah, go ahead, Adrian. Get ready.
Hello.
Hello, can you hear me? Yeah, I can hear
you, my friend, Yossi.
What's going on?
I'm good. How are you?
I'm okay, buddy.
Yossi, Yossi.
What's up with you?
How you doing?
I don't know.
And before we start, I do want to ask
you a question, right? So, I don't know.
you are a I don't know if you want I
don't know if you can ask me a question,
but what is it?
And you are a Syrian, right?
Why is that?
I asked you are are you are are you a
Syrian?
I mean, but what what does that matter
to the discussion, just curiously?
I don't know. I mean, I was I was I was
curious anyway. I'm fine. I can continue
now.
What are you, my friend? I was a
Ashkenazi. Ashkenazi Jew, yeah. I'm I'm
Ashuri. I'm Assyrian.
Mhm. Yeah, but I'm Jew. Why How does
that affect our conversation though,
just curiously?
No, it doesn't. I was asking and I don't
know why.
>> man? Come on, tell me. Why do you want
to know I'm Assyrian? Is it because Is
it because we go way way back? We're
ancient rivals, is that it? Mhm. I mean,
yeah, Nebuchadnezzar, you know,
Nebuchadnezzar. You know, the vice king
of Assyria,
and yeah, I mean, Yeah, well, it's not
just Nebuchadnezzar, Sennacherib,
Shalmaneser, Sargon, Tiglath-Pileser,
right? Mhm. Okay, but anyway, yeah,
yeah, because I thought maybe you still
have some hatred and grudge in your
heart because of my ancestors.
No, I have no I have no hatred to
Nineveh, Nineveh, Nineveh, Nineveh. I
have no hatred to the no hatred to the
SC
So when I saw you from the SC Dawah
Channel, what were you doing at the SC
Dawah Channel?
I speak with a lot of the people you
know, with the you know, people like
people like people like SC Dawah as
well.
Generally on the you know, Christianity
and the generally on the you know, the
tie of Islam and Judaism when it comes
to you know, belief in one God.
>> So let's let's try this Yossi slowly
because you're talking too fast. Mhm.
See this actually confirms to me that
someone who doesn't have
Jesus is of the same spirit. So you
would go on a Muslim channel
to agree with Muslims over against
Christians and yet they believe Jesus is
Messiah born of the Virgin Mary. Are
they right?
No, I disagree with that statement.
Okay, so do they are they right? Are
they right the Muslims that you dialogue
with?
Are they right about Jesus being a
Messiah?
>> Mary and the Messiah?
I disagree with them. They are not right
about that concept. No.
>> and they also believe in the Quran
chapter 4:171.
Jesus the Messiah is
Karimatahu al-Qaha il la Maryam. This
the word of Allah that he cast down to
Mary arukhan min.
Are they right?
No. Okay. They also believe if they're
Sunni Muslim because SC Dawah they're
Sunni Muslim because I want to get you
on record.
They believe Jesus is the Messiah is
going to come back and kill al Masih al
Dajjal the Antichrist and you Jews are
going to follow the Dajjal
because you're going to be blind and
deceived into accepting him because you
rejected Jesus the Messiah. Are they
right?
No, I disagree with them. So why in the
world would you be on their channel
helping them refute Christianity? Are
you not being dishonest and
inconsistent?
No, Yianni because of the fact that we
are the Muslims are considered by the
general population of you know, Jewish
scholars such as you know, the Rambam
such as you know, the Kaigon etc. As
what is called Bnei Noach, not
necessarily Noachide.
>> talk too fast Yossi. If you want people
to understand, you don't
Calm down, buddy. There's no rush. Just
slowly. All right. Okay. Well, then they
are considered by the general majority
of Jewish scholars like the Rambam, like
the going in a status called almost,
which means in Hebrew, you know, pious
among the nations. Are they not
necessarily
they are called
because the fact that their religion
leads them to believe in the one in the
one God that God is all
>> Okay, let's let's break that down. Let's
break down your logic cuz we're going to
come into what the Hebrew scriptures say
about the nature of God. Okay, but
before you do that So, you're saying
that your Orthodox rabbis say that
because they believe in one God somehow
they're pious among them. So, do you
believe the Quran is the eternal
uncreated speech of God?
No.
So, do you believe that their view that
the Quran is the eternal uncreated
speech of Allah
somehow is
perfectly compatible with your view of
the oneness of God?
Well, they don't necessarily consider
like the written Are you speaking of the
written Quran? Are you going to uh It's
irrelevant what I'm speaking cuz the
written Quran is the scripturation of
the eternal Quran. So, and you can't
distinguish the written from the spoken
because the Quran says it's a kitab, a
book. So, we're not going to play
semantics here because the Quran, even
the book, is the uncreated speech of
Allah. In fact, if you know Islamic
history
Al-Bukhari who tried to distinguish and
differentiate between the Quran as the
speech of Allah and the book, he was
accused of heresy even though later on
people adopted his position. So, but my
question is the Quran that they touch
and recite
that is supposed to be the uncreated
speech of Allah in book. It's in
scripturated. Is that compatible with
your view of the oneness of God?
Well, I believe well, the difference I
mean, technically, yes, but the
difference between us and the Christians
and Muslims
the difference between us and the
Muslims is that our difference in the in
the idea of God is God's decision. So,
whether or not God chose to, you know,
Muhammad to be a prophet, whether or not
God revealed the Quran, I believe the
idea that he
>> No, it's more than that because the
speech of God became a book and it's the
Quran. It's more than just a difference
whether Muhammad's a prophet. It's their
belief the Quran is the eternal speech
of God. In fact, there was early debates
among Muslims that they started
persecuting each other
and even had people flogged and beaten,
thrown in jail depending on what they
said about the Quran, created or
uncreated. And you know the Mu'tazili as
well as the what later became Ahl
al-Sunna wal-Jama'ah. So, that's not an
answer to my question. Are they
compatible? Their view of God, Allah
being one and the Quran being the
uncreated speech that became book, is
that compatible with your view of the
oneness of God?
Uh
technically, yes, because in my view it
is a
It is my my view the difference is
decisioning, not necessarily attributes.
>> So, God's word can become a book?
Uh no, if you meant in, you know,
written on paper as in it's a part of
the physical
>> Yeah, I know. If we're going to talk
like this, man, I don't know if you're
not wasting my time. Let me repeat it
again. The Quran
is the eternal speech of God that became
a book. It's a kitab, but it's eternal.
So, can the eternal word of God become a
book in your view?
No, I don't believe that God's word can
become
>> Okay, say it again. One more time on the
paper.
>> not believe
I do not believe that God's word can
become eternal co-eternal with a book.
Okay. No, we didn't say co-eternal with
the book. The book is God's eternal word
that became a book.
Do you believe that? His eternal word
became a book?
Uh
no, not the Quran.
>> Okay. So, can you stop being a hypocrite
and going to the Muslim channels bashing
Christian because I'm going to start
bashing you cuz I want to call you out
for your hypocrisy.
Can you stop now?
I mean, I don't necessarily in my my
interaction with Muslims, I I I've asked
them about this as well and they
generally say no, the Quran
>> necessarily call them Well, they're
lying to you. If you're talking to Shia,
that's a different story. So, the SC
Dow, they're Shia? Are you lying to me
or they're lying to you? One of you guys
are lying to me. Who's lying to me?
Uh
I don't know. I mean, I've been like I
said, I mainly speak with Sunni Muslims.
So, I'm
>> So, then Sunni Muslim, there is no Sunni
Muslim if he's a true Muslim unless he's
doing taqiyyah. He's lying like his
Allah is the greatest of all deceivers,
khairul makireen.
Sunni Muslim says Quran is kalam Allah,
it's uncreated. Uncreated and it
emanates from Allah. So, if they're
telling you that it's not, then they're
lying to you. But, since you are
supposedly educated and you study Sunni
Islam, then you know they're lying to
you. So, am I now going to hear you go
to their channel and say, "We don't have
the same view of God's oneness cuz you
believe the word can become a book and I
deny that. You believe Jesus Messiah
born of a virgin and I believe he's a
false Messiah." I want you to say that
in their channel instead of going there
bashing Christians to your shame. Are
you going to do that?
Well, I I mean, first I need to do you
know, more research into this instead
Oh, you'll see. So, you did enough
research to attack Christianity and join
hands with Muslims, but you didn't make
sure to do enough research to study what
Islam says about Jesus or the nature of
God before you went on their channels to
bash Christians. Are you not a
hypocrite?
Well, I knew that they believed the same
thing about Jesus, but they did not
believe that Jesus was divine in the way
so I didn't really know
>> let's let's take this step by step.
According to even their view, Jesus is
not divine. How do you hold hands with
Muslims who say he is the Messiah and
that your ancestors are condemned in
Surat An-Nisa, chapter 4, verse 157 for
saying, "We killed the Messiah, Jesus
son of Mary." Do you believe the Jews
said that to Muhammad?
Uh
I mean, there might have been some Jews
who said it to Muhammad. I'm not sure.
So, you call Jesus the Messiah. So, you
you killed your Messiah. So, you deserve
to burn in hell with your rabbis. Cuz
the sex says that the Jews say we killed
Messiah, Jesus.
That's chapter 41:57.
>> didn't say that they did kill Al Masih.
I don't think they killed him. That's
what the Quran says your ancestors said
to Muhammad. As is it right or wrong?
Is the Quran wrong in that regard? Yes.
Say it again.
Is the Quran wrong in the saying that
the Jews came to Muhammad and said, "You
know, we have killed Al Masih, you know,
Jesus."
Then they'd be wrong. Okay, and yet you
still go on their channels to bash
Christians because you think they're
closer to you than we are to you, right?
Yes. Oh, at least you admit you're a
hypocrite and a tool of the devil. I
appreciate you. You're very honest and I
respect that.
Now, another thing
>> Well, I do. Before you go to the Tanakh,
in chapter 9, verse 30, Surat Al-Tawbah,
chapter 9, verse 30.
Did Muhammad lie when he said your
ancestors say that Uzair Ezra is the son
of Allah? And on that grounds the
Muhammadan Muslims should attack you
Jews and subjugate you until you pay
jizya.
Well, the general interpretation of
Tafsir of that verse is especially by,
you know, people who are Mufassirun
like, you know, Ibn Hazm, generally take
that as a sect of Jews, you know, from
Arabia.
>> can I can I put holes through Ibn Hazm's
lie?
Sure. I mean, I I agree Ibn Hazm was not
the most brightest person, but
>> No,
forget Ibn Hazm. Number one, let them
show you any source other other than the
Quran and the Muslims pointing to such a
Jewish sect.
What proof do they have apart from the
Muslims? Give me the proof.
I don't dis- I mean, I don't disagree.
My uh
Second point.
>> disagree with you. Okay, second point.
>> disagree with you, brother. In the
context, the Jews are being likened to
Christians, not a sect of them, but it's
assumed this is a common belief, so
common that they imitate Christians in
saying Jesus is the son of Allah. That's
the verse. The Jews say "Uzair is the
son of Allah." and the Christians say
"The Messiah is the son of Allah." So,
it's saying the Jews are like Christians
in the generality cuz it's a general
belief of Christians that Jesus is the
son of God, not simply a sect. Do you
agree that's right? That the Jews also
in their generality believe Ezra is the
son of Allah?
No. And yet you still join them, my
goodness, on their channel to bash
Christians.
Wow.
I want to say shame on you, but you have
no shame because if you had shame and
honor, you wouldn't do that. But, that's
okay. You show that you belong to the
same spirit that inspired Muhammad and
your rabbi. So, glory to Jesus for that.